[Musique]
c'est une chose horrible qui était
arrivé mais tu dois recommencer à vivre
ta vie
dans mes bras ça fera bientôt un an j'ai
planifié un projet et cherche une
complice de crime la tour de télévision
B67 j'ai pas fait d'escalade depuis je
comprends mais si tu refuses de
confronter tes peurs toute ta vie te
rappeur
d'accord on le fait
alors escalader ta stupides doux
[Musique]
j'étais vraiment bourré merde t'es
incroyable c'est cette béquille qu'il
nous faut pour le voyage
ça c'est cinglé merde
[Musique]
un échelon à la fois et tu me dis si tu
veux faire une halte
[Musique]
tu vois c'est facile
tu te débrouilles bien
c'est qui tu dois monter ici
et confiance en moi
j'ai pas de raison
notre sac est en bas je le vois on a une
corde de 15 mètres
[Musique]
à chaque heure qui passe on s'affaiblit
ça fait maintenant 24 heures
qu'est-ce que donne disait toujours si
tu as peur de mourir n'aie pas peur de
vivre